>> BELIEVE THAT'S A MISSILE.
>> KIEV, UKRAINE, IS UNDER SIEGE
TONIGHT.
RUSSIAN TROOPS HAVE ENTERED THE
CITY.
JOINING ME NOW IS A MEMBER OF
THE TRAINING PARLIAMENT AND
FORMER CAMPAIGN ADVISOR TO
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY.
YOU WENT VIRAL FOR BRANDISHING
AN AK-47, VOWING TO FIGHT FOR
YOUR COUNTRY.
RUSSIAN FORCES ARE NOW INSIDE
THE CITY DURING WHAT'S NEXT FOR
YOU?
>> WHAT IS HAPPENING EVERYWHERE
IS KNOWN KYIV.
I HEAR PLENTY OF SHOOTING ON THE
STREETS, AND -- THROUGH
PARLIAMENT, WHO ARE JOINING THE
FIGHT.
YESTERDAY, WE WERE PLANNING AND
BRINGING GUNS TO TRY AND GIVE IT
TO EVERYONE WHO WANTS TO JOIN IN
THE BATTLE YESTERDAY, WE
ENCOURAGED -- WE PUSHED THEM
OUT.
WE WILL NOT BE INDIFFERENT,
USING THE NIGHT TO TRY AND
SURPRISE.
KYIV IS A CITY OF MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE.
THEY ARE FIGHTING BACK, AND HAVE
BEEN FOR THE LAST 48 HOURS.
WE ARE VERY CONFIDENT ABOUT THE
REALITY THAT EVERYBODY HERE
WANTS TO DEFEND THEIR COUNTRY
AND CITY UNTIL THE END.
>> WE UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
THOUSANDS UPON THOUSANDS OF YOUR
FELLOW COUNTRYMEN WHO HAVE MADE
THEIR WAY TO MAKE SURE OTHERS
ARE SHELTERED.
WE'VE SEEN THE PICTURES FROM THE
UNDERGROUND, PEOPLE TAKING THEIR
PETS AND AS MUCH FOOD AS THEY
CAN CARRY.
WE ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT INTERNET
HAS BEEN CUT, IN LARGE PARTS OF
THE COUNTRY, ALONG WITH FOOD
SHORTAGES AND GASOLINE SHORTAGES
THROUGHOUT THE LAND AS WELL.
IS THAT ACCURATE?
>> WE ARE SEEING OCCUPATION
CONTINUE AT A PLACE WHERE PEOPLE
ARE LOSING EVERYTHING THEY HAVE,
WE HAVE SEEN PLENTY OF CIVILIAN
TARGETS.
THERE IS NO END OF MISERY ALL
AROUND.
CAN THE REALITY OF THE
MISSIONS -- COMING IN -- IT'S
HARD TO DISCERN -- NOT HARD TO
POINT THIS OUT, BUT AS FAR AS
KYIV'S CONCERN, WE HAVE IMPROVED
ON THAT YESTERDAY.
THIS SHALL BE NO DIFFERENT.
WE ARE TRYING TO SHOWCASE THE
RUSSIANS -- IT'S NOT WORKING
HERE.
THE MISSION FOR THE PRESIDENT TO
DESTROY US SHALL NOT SUCCEED.
>> WE ARE SHOWING SOME VIDEO
RIGHT NOW THAT YOU SENT US.
YOU SAY THESE ARE RUSSIAN
POWs.
HAVE THEY REVEALED ANYTHING
ABOUT WHAT THEIR OBJECTIVES
WERE, WHAT THEY THOUGHT THE
MISSION WAS COMING IN TO
UKRAINE?
>> THEY ARE ALL FROM ALL OVER
UKRAINE.
THEY ARE FROM THE SOUTH OF
UKRAINE, THE EAST OF UKRAINE,
THE NORTH OF UKRAINE.
THE RUSSIANS ARE BASICALLY
SENDING CRUISE MISSILES TO HIT
UKRAINE COME EVERYWHERE AROUND
THE COUNTRY.
AS FAR AS THEIR UNITS, WE HAD A
WHOLE PLATOON OF UNITS IN THE
NORTH OF THE COUNTRY.
THEY BECAME PRISONERS OF WAR.
WE ARE GETTING A LOT OF THOSE
REPORTS, A LOT OF INFORMATION.
THAT'S A DIFFERENT STORY FROM
WHAT YOU MIGHT BE GETTING
PERSONALLY, BUT THE REALITY IS
THIS IS A MASSIVE INVASION IN
WHICH A LOT OF RUSSIANS ARE
DYING, A LOT ARE GOING TO BECOME
PRISONERS.
THE CLAIM -- FROM THE RUSSIAN
CHIEF OF THE ARMOR THAT THEY
HAVE LOST NOBODY, THERE'S A LOT
OF COMPILATION VIDEOS AND
RESPONSES FOR RUSSIANS.
>> THE SENSE FROM AMERICAN MEDIA
IS THAT THIS WAS KIND OF
INEVITABLE, THAT IT WAS
INEVITABLE THAT RUSSIA WAS GOING
TO COME INTO KYIV.
DID YOU THINK IT WAS?
WHAT COULD HAVE BEEN DONE TO
PREVENT THIS?
>> THE REALITY WAS VERY SIMPLE.
IF THERE WERE ANY KIND OF --
DESTROYING RUSSIAN WEAPONRY AND
TROOPS WITH AMERICAN WEAPONS --
STAYING THROUGH EVERYTHING WE'VE
GOT, AND -- NOTHING IS ALSO SO
MUCH AS FAR AS FIGHTING THE
WORLD'S LARGEST ARMIES, ONE OF
THEM.
THE SECOND QUESTION, WHAT COULD
HAVE BEEN DONE TO PREVENT THIS,
LOTS OF IDEAS COME TO MIND.
RUSSIA DOES NOT WANT TO WILL
HIMSELF TO BE ESTONIA, WHICH HAS
A LARGE RUSSIAN POPULATION JUST
ACROSS THE BORDER.
STILL, A NATO MEMBERSHIP,
DOESN'T WANT TO DO THAT.
THE POINT FOR US, THAT'S WHY WE
HAVE PURSUED A NATO MEMBERSHIP.
GET THIS SECURITY --
>> I KNOW YOU HAVE TO MOVE
LOCATIONS, BECAUSE YOU
PE